ce vendredi une manifestation pour
dénoncer l'insécurité dans le nord kivu
a mal tourné a béni un manifestant il ya
trouvé la mort la faute à une balle
perdue tirée par un membre des forces de
l'ordre
celle ci dit avoir tiré des coups de feu
alors que des protestataires jeté des
pierres sur des policiers occupés à
dégager une barrière sur la voie
publique
ce rassemblement d'activistes visé a
dénoncé les tueries dans la province
dans sept villes de la rdc comme
ailleurs dans l'est du pays la
population et victimes de massacres
incessants notamment par les adf
d'origine ougandaise considéré comme le
groupe armé le plus meurtrier selon
human rights watch
la police a blessé par balles au moins
un activiste et a arrêté des dizaines
d'autres le bureau conjoint des nations
unies pour les droits de l'homme
présente en rdc s'est dit préoccupé par
ces violences policières
la liberté de manifester pacifiquement
est un droit fondamental reconnu par la
constitution
et elle appelle les manifestants de
s'abstenir de tout recours ou appels à
la violence contraires à l'exercice
légitime des droits et libertés les
groupes armés ne sont pas les seuls
pointé du doigt la population
s'interroge sur l'efficacité de l'armée
et de la monusco la mission onusienne
présente dans l'est du pays depuis 1999
pour maintenir la paix dans le pays
l'onu a ainsi mobilisé un contingent de
15 mille militaires dont la mission
principale est de protéger les civils
mais les violences perdurent et les
congolais reprochent aux militaires de
l'onu leur passivité et demande leur
départ lundi une grève de 10 jours a été
décrété dans plusieurs villes du pays
on demande aux autorités de mettre et on
en marche pour que nous puissions voir
que la monusco puissent rentrer chez eux
ce n'est pas normal qu'on continue à
tuer les gens béni et nous en tant que
des citoyens nous puissions rester dans
les sécurité et que la monusco rester là
sans pour autant intervenir pour aider
manifester notre ras le bol
qu'est ce qui était prévu que nous
passions et ils manifestation pacifique
pour des modèles et des pales de la
monusco et la police ne nous a pas
permis complices nous manifester
librement ils nous ont été réprimées une
population qui se sent délaissée par son
président félix tshisekedi dont l'une
des promesses de sa campagne avant son
élection à la tête du pays étaient la
faim de l'insécurité dans la région
depuis 2013
les massacres ont fait plus de 6000
morts rien que dans la ville ce mercredi
bintou keita la chef de la monusco a
exprimé sa préoccupation face aux appels
à la violence et à la haine qui se
multiplient dans les zones de béni
butembo et lubero notamment à l'encontre
des humanitaires et des institutions
nationales et internationales